it seems like almost
no war is just
but it also seems somehow deeply human
to fight
and i think your book makes the case no
it's not can you can you try to like get
at that because it seems that war there
is some that
like drama of war seems to beat in all
human hearts like it's in there
somewhere maybe it's
maybe there's like a relic of the past
and we need to get rid of it it's deeply
irrational
okay so obviously we go to war and
obviously there's a lot of violence and
so
we have to explain something and and
some of that's going to be aspects of
our humanness so so i guess what i
wanted us to sort of start with
i think it was just useful to sort of
start and point out actually you know
there's really really really really
strong incentives not to go to war
because it's going to be really costly
and so all of these other human or
strategic things all these things the
circumstantial things that will
eventually lead us to go to war have to
be pretty
powerful before we go there and and most
of the time sorry to interrupt
and that's you why you also describe
very importantly that war throughout
human history is actually rare
we usually avoid it
you know most people don't know about
the us invasion of haiti in 1994. i mean
i mean a lot of people know about it but
people just don't pay attention to it we
don't we we're gonna you know the
history books and school kids are gonna
learn about the invasion afghanistan for
decades and decades and nobody is going
to put this one in the
in the history books and it's because it
it didn't actually happen because
uh before the troops could land
the person who'd taken power in a coup
basically said fine
there's a famous story where where colin
powell goes to haiti to this new
dictator who's refused to let a
democratic president take power
and um
and tries to convince him to step down
or else and he says no no and and then
he shows them a video and it's basically
troop planes and all these things taking
off
and he's like this is not live this is
two hours ago so
it's a and and basically he basically
gives up right there
so that was that's a powerful move yeah
i think powell might have been one of
his teachers in like a u.s military
college because a lot of these military
dictators trained at some point so they
had some there was some personal
relationships at least between people in
the u.s government and this guy that
they were trying to use the the point is
and that that's that's like what should
have happened like that makes sense
right like yeah i'm
maybe i can mount an insurgency and yeah
i'm not going to bear a lot of the cost
of work because i'm the dictator and
maybe he's human and he just wants to
fight or gets angry or it's just in his
mind whatever he's doing but at the end
of days like this does not make sense
um
and that's what happens most of the time
but we don't write so many books about
it
and uh
and and and now some political
scientists go and they count up all of
the nations that could fight because
they have some dispute and they're right
next to another one another or they look
at the ethnic groups that could fight
with one another because they have
there's some tension and they're right
next to one another and
and then whatever some number like 999
out of a thousand don't fight
um because they just find some other way
they don't like each other but they they
just loathe in peace because that's the
sensible thing to do
and that's what we all do we loathe in
peace uh and we loathed the soviet union
in relative peace for decades and india
loathes pakistan in peace i mean two
weeks into the russian invasion of
ukraine again
it was in the newspapers but most people
didn't i think take note india
accidentally launched a cruise missile
at pakistan
and
common suit so they were like yeah this
is
we do not want to go to war this will be
bad
uh
we'll ex will be angry but we'll accept
your explanation that this was an
accident and so um so these things fine
under the radar
and so we overestimate i think how
likely it is sides are gonna fight but
then of course things do happen like
russia did invade the ukraine and didn't
find some
a deal and so
uh and so then the book is sort of about
half the book it's just sort of laying
out
actually like there's just different
ways this breaks down and some of them
are human
some of them are this
i i actually don't think war beats in
our heart it does a little bit but
we're actually very cooperative we're as
a species we're deeply deeply
cooperative we're really really good so
the thing we're not we're okay at
violence and we're okay and we're okay
getting angry and vengeant and we have
principles that will sometimes lead us
but we're actually really really really
good at cooperation
and and so that's again you know i i
don't i'm not trying to write some big
optimistic book where everything's going
to be great and we're all happy and we
don't really fight it's more just to say
let's start let's be like a doctor as a
doctor we're going to focus on the sick
right i'm going to try i know there's
sick people but i'm going to recognize
that the normal state is health and that
most people are healthy
and and that's going to make me a better
doctor and that's i'm kind of saying the
same thing let's be better doctors of
politics in the world by recognizing
that like normal state is health and
then we're going to
identify like what are the diseases that
are causing this warfare
you